let's say you have a bubble around you
and you know who you are and then the
bubble gets popped yeah
for whatever reason oh it will oh okay
it will it'll get popped oh yeah oh yeah
yeah
bubbles get popped because and it comes
from disappointment right most often you
you are this close to your most perfect
imagine deal was a book or is with a
producer and you're ah and you can taste
it and you're already buying your house
in Malibu you're so excited because all
of your dreams have come through it's on
your list and then something falls apart
and that's the moment where every story
that you've ever told yourself or
anyone's ever told you about how you're
not going to succeed comes ringing and
it's this echoing voice that's that
you're afraid that you're manifesting
and proof that again the universe hates
me that is going to happen that is going
to happen it's it's recognizing that
obstacles are not our external and
there's a difference between what
happens to you in the world and your
willingness to believe in yourself over
the external and it's it's not you know
I'm not somebody who believes in like
karma well you you know you you somehow
deserve this or you needed this right
but I do believe that the stronger that
core is that allows you to know who you
are and know what value you bring to the
world the easier it is to overcome that
the shorter time your disappointment
gets
and the key is how you frame the story
this is the most important thing how you
frame the story of your disappointments
so if you truly believe as I do that
it's the story is never over until that
the ending is happy so when that bubble
is burst I've just hit the end of the
third act it's the moment where the
hero's lost everything the worst thing
that could possibly happen has happened
and I know the next thing that happens
the next scene is the hero pulls
themselves together and figures out how
to overcome it and so it's always my
choice is this story gonna gonna end
sooner or later and the sooner I pull
myself together and go to go have the
showdown with the villain which is
internally and myself my own self-doubt
the sooner I know the stories can end
happily do you have some rituals you do
to kind of like okay I get 24 hours to
grieve or I get 48 hours or a week and
then now back on up I use something
that's probably really counterintuitive
which is that I know that every negative
story that I'm telling myself holds it
longer so the faster I can first tell
myself this is a negative story I'm
telling myself right that's the first
thing I say the story that the reason
that I'm crying is because I'm telling
myself a really crappy story and at the
moment I'm believing it and that sucks
too I really wish I could stop believing
this crappy story 3 I'm not there yet
but soon I'll stop believing this crappy
story for well it's not as crappy as it
was yesterday so I must be getting
better but I still hate this crappy
story so it's just this progression of
distancing myself from the crappy story
the crappy story is not me it's not
truth it's not reality and as
storytellers we all know how powerful
stories are and the
powerful story is the story I'm telling
myself and as soon as I realize that
this is just a story I'm telling myself
and if I just told myself the story that
oh my gosh I just ended the third act
I'm so close to the end and the happy
ending then I would get excited and I
would get over that crappy story sooner
and sooner I can get to that the better
it goes so I'm I'm not a big believer in
I'm a believer in the the shortest
amount of wallowing as possible and if I
can't get there at least I can say at
least I know this is a story and not
real
you